der heurige nationalfeiertag ist ein
ganz besonderer für das österreichische
bundesheer wir können einerseits unsere
neue gerätschaften präsentieren wir
können den aufwuchs im österreichischen
bundesheer präsentieren wir können
präsentieren dass wir für die sicherheit
der österreicherinnen und österreich
bestens vorbereitet sind
aber es ist auch ein besonderer
nationalfeiertag für mich aller
voraussicht nach wird das mein letzter
nationalfeiertag als
verteidigungsminister sein es ist auch
ein besonderer nationalfeiertag weil wir
über 1300 kunden heuer angehoben werden
kann man sie besuchen sie uns hier in
wien überzeugen sie sich von der
leistungsfähigkeit des österreichischen
bundesheeres und überzeugen sie sich
davon
das österreichische bundesheer für ihre
sicherheit garantieren kann